that i have it
okay so i can uh you can see that
there's a question before i can cook you
[Music]
one down or not if you lose your balance
and you take a chemical
but that's not my uh goal okay
i can get on the outside
just no no rules
uh and then try so you can make it like
that he's in
and then i can do that right
but i can also let him just hit it i can
play with my tokyo
[Music]
okay okay
so in training you'll have a lot of i'm
over here
and then um you'll see me actively
project but
that's training to to advance
and you get the keyhole you want to do
the keyhole well
you the techniques actually load him on
me okay so as opposed to going here
and then you yes you project it into a
center
but uh find the kazushi angle
where he will just hit hit it hit
they're all different
sit in here i try to advance
so i'm loading the angle
your technique can get smaller which is
what you want
combatively i don't want to be out here
i'm involved
okay okay so you have to have to advance
on hitting the spot
versus me uh projecting through
but as as we go um
i'm gonna you can see kokinagi right
okay
so it's not that i'm here there's no way
on and then he hits us
because i'm using the ground path
to neutralize the yong and get a yong
yang match that's the ik
legion so as we're going here it's not
uh dead he can push and we're not going
anywhere it's just going into the ground
okay and so anywhere in the throat then
you can see that i can rebound and go
coq projection
here boom
here
so it's not dead until here
it's alive oh
oh it's alive
oh push alive
alive so he's put push at me
you see which means i can project
while i wait for the kazushi pattern
until he loads it is the
arc
but part of the art is that it's not
moving
and then here
because i need this adhesion i need us
to be
stuck okay and in order to show that i'm
stuck
i can increase my young output and
you'll see the calculator
okay
so he's going to
move around not one line you're going to
try to move around
and if i'm stuck i'll it won't matter
[Music]
you won't lose it
you gotta
[Music]
and again maybe at this level you got to
go back to the actual projection
but if you can just keep loading them
okay okay you you need a detail on the
uk so he's coming in and he he's staying
up
we made contact here and so he pushes
you see he's being
connected to the ground okay and he
feels that so he feels that i have
control of his center don't count her
yet
he feels that i have control of the
center you see so
he's going to yin around it you see
that's what he's trying to do so we're
here
he goes and make a technique out of it
he comes around
right and we're here
or uh i have a knife he goes to block it
rather than
here i'll go around it in step
i'm free my center okay
he's not walking in anymore and doing
that he's gonna feel
his center connected you feel it so you
can see as i move you see i moved him
he's going to try to free it but i'm
going to stay connected to his center
you see i'll show you again you see he's
still in there i still have it
it's not that he's just doing the first
drill and then he's
allowing his center to be king he's
getting your center okay so free it
again
that's it he's
he's countering him okay it's gonna
build sensitivity in him
and it's gonna build sophistication in
me okay
so we're in oh you'll see i'm gonna
demonstrate what's happening okay
so he's his energy is being taken to the
ground
and now i have his center so i can move
his center
and i can project his center so
i'm going to have the ik adhesion i have
a cochlea projection
but he feels he feels the center so he
frees it but i have to be able to keep
his center under my control
these people don't just do one thing
so he's in and again you'll see
no i don't want to show first you can
see ikey adhesion
coking projection he doesn't want his
center manipulated
so he's going to try to free it and
you'll see i don't really have this hand
okay i have to keep connection
whoa and find the adhesion over here
so this is a coaching tip for uke he's
still going to come in
i don't want to have to be out here and
we're doing a
sticky hands drill okay he's still
pressing on me he still has a social
uh spinal displacement sure
but i'm not contesting him i'm not
trying to stop him
i'm yielding but i'm not getting out of
the way like a bullfighter
i'm just utilizing the ik lesion part
so we're still stuck here i'll show you
we're still stuck warm and i use it
but he's trying to free each note so
again
we're i already have it you can see boom
the two forces
so he tries to free it you see he's
gonna get free right now if i don't do
anything
but i am gonna do something still here
i'll show you again i
get adhesion goku projection
he moves again same thing if i don't if
i disconnect
he's going to get it but i don't
disconnect though
again much ikey adhesion coq projection
so he's trying to counter all this
you see there it is but i still have the
center
through those two forces so uki is
trying to go around
yes there you go
you feel it and he's gonna go around it
there he goes
boom
[Music]
and that's what we're doing with this
quicker
[Music]
all right i think at this pace he's
countering i should not
i should not lose the arm control
so you could sing
it's just too slow you i can always find
the connect
but as he goes quicker right oh
look go back you see
i'm a little tight here you see that
okay so uh
if i i get it but it's time you see the
lag did you see the lag
okay so what i can do instead is bring
it to my shoulder and then there's no
lagging again
okay so i have to get used to
uh this is not about hand
and stay on the elbows and control the
elbows it's not about that
it's about this energetic manipulation
of his body
and therefore as he comes in i can use
any part of my body to do the same thing
okay
same exact thing
[Music]
and let's say he gets in gets my head
right same same thing here look
i don't need to try to escape
i can still so you you're going to see a
push push you see we're here against
ground vector
and this is the yin hand now
doing the adhesion on the projection
so i don't need to escape i keep the
connection
and you'll have it it's almost it's this
is
losing connection i'm gonna lose him
back energy here keep the connection
boom sometimes he's
touching my chest okay oh you do the
same thing do you see
so
[Music]
the projection i don't have to go
he's there same drill
[Music]
it's not only on the hands here
same thing push is the ground vector
the projection the adhesion
so it looks like i lost it and then
you're going to want to go like that and
that's where you lose connection
so instead use whatever you're touching
he's going around my arm and you start
chasing the arm
use whatever you're touching he's going
around my arm oh
that's good they're still there
so i'm gonna take away the young hat and
you can see
push under the ground vector
you can see the friction friction
it's plenty fine he's here
same thing i don't need to clear it i
need to connect it
same exact way
you got to free your mind it's not about
hand control
it's about energetic control oh same
thing here it looks like a clinch
it's not a clinch with no connection i
still have the connection
so i'm gonna lose it no no it's just now
on the shoulder
and of course you could go i'll go a
little on the shoulder
and then i'm gonna pick back up on the
arm you can do that
but what you can't do is forgo the
shoulder and try to hit the arm you're
not going to get the arm you lost
connection already
boom
no more aggression
here
shoulder oh
using his grip don't need my grip
the energy's there come up
come on doesn't matter
go out it doesn't matter back in
push through it doesn't matter it's on
this shoulder now
okay bring your mind